winter is coming but somebody just
turned up fade spoils of war Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 4 reminder I do
not - spoiler free anymore so here we go
let's get right into it I'm going to say
the best part which if you hadn't
guessed is the tail end and the big
battle at the end we're going to come
back to that because I'm afraid if I
start gushing about that too much I am
going to forget to talk about the stuff
in the earlier part of the episode which
I'm a little more mixed on very little
was outright bad but it wasn't awesome
until the ending so we're going to come
back to that so what do we got well we
got Daenerys in John a little bit more
I'm still liking their vibe and their
dynamic Daenerys irritated me a little
bit because she was kind of falling back
on her oh I don't know some of her more
pigheaded tendencies which I will grant
makes more sense here than it has in
some of the cases in the past because I
mean she's losing and she certainly
wasn't expecting that she's watching the
plans that have been carefully curated
not come together so I get why she's
sort of in the headspace that she is and
I think the way that she chose to use
the dragon was about the smartest thing
that she could do as far as that goes
because she's using it in a military
sense which she kind of needs - she
needed to have a strong show of force at
this at this point and this definitely
qualified but at the same time it's like
John said she can't just use it to take
over King's Landing because there's
civilians on the ground who will
absolutely be terrified of her and then
she's no better than Searcy and if she
does actually care about these people
which she claims to she can't do that so
to keep it to a battlefield where the
only casualties are soldiers smart move
again we'll come back to that fight so
what else have we got well we got Arya
getting herself back to Winterfell boy
characters are crossing the the land and
sea a lot faster for this season we had
John instantly in the upper Dragon zone
and now Arya turns it around and very
next episode she's back in Winterfell I
remember when it took Ned and Rob
baratheon like three episodes to get
from Winterfell to King's Landing man
times have changed
anyway so Ari is back and she gets
initially a reunion with Santa which was
awkward which it should have been I
think given how those two characters
felt about each other the last time they
did see each other
and how much each of them has been
through I really liked Arya's button
fight with Brienne of Tarth I thought
that I mean I liked both those
characters I like that they have a
different dynamic
I like that Arya life was all nimble and
everything but that Brienne got that
really solid kick in on her chest and I
think put in whether or not arya took
this lesson I'm not sure but it was a
good reminder to me that Arya is not
indestructible and if she gets hit
especially by someone like Brienne it
could go real bad for her real quick so
I enjoyed that fight I thought it was
cool and the other while the other bit
of reunion we had for Arya was a reunion
with bran and brand they need to think
of something to do with this guy really
really quick because he is boring and I
say that as someone who I don't want to
think offended bran previously but I
never got on the brand hate train that a
lot of people and fans that I know have
been on for years I haven't had an issue
with that because I found his story of
his journey interesting but now that he
sort of hid what his immediate
destination was and become the
three-eyed Raven man the guy's boring
and I get that we've kind of gotten an
explanation as to why he's behaving the
way it he is but they better start
having him do plot vital stuff right
away because right now they've only had
him in these scenes that would work if I
cared about him emotionally and this one
I really really don't
he had one cool moment and that was
unnerving a little finger which was a
cool moment Littlefinger he I think he
also really took notice of Arya and I
think he know recognized a potential
threat that she is and I also took note
that Sansa seems to be in a good
headspace as far as understanding how
untrustworthy Littlefinger is which is
good be
because my fear was that he was gonna
corrupt her and while that may still
happen at the very least it doesn't look
like she's going to be a pushover if it
goes that way so I I appreciate that a
completely random thing I hope I I'm not
sure it's going to happen I'm going to
say I don't think it will but it is my
hope that Arya will stab Littlefinger to
death with that dagger I would
appreciate that greatly I don't think
he's on our list though another person
not doing much of the moment Cersei and
I guess just because of what's going on
there isn't much for her to do if I just
plot and scheme which she's good at
don't get me wrong but she's very
detached from all the goings on and
maybe that's why they gave her Mark
Davis to play off of and man that guy
just smug really really well so that's
it's not a bad point yet but I hope they
figure out more for her or just in
general e stuff to go on in King's
Landing because yeah right now it's fine
it's not being overdone but it is it is
a little detached but let's get to the
big set piece of this which is of course
that battle okay so starts off when we
just got with sounds almost like thunder
and then oh that's a horde of Dothraki
and there's the dragon and like I said
Daenerys being very smart very strategic
with the fire breath of the day and oh
my god reducing people to ash instantly
and then they blow away in the wind whoo
that was intense and I I mean for god
sake it was like she brought a nuclear
bomb to a sword fight that was crazy
I like that Tyrion was there because
we're really getting I just threw some
great expressions from Peter Dinklage
how hard this is for him because yes he
chose his side and I don't think he's
questioning that but it wasn't an easy
thing for him to see Jaime's to see his
brother in danger and he might hate
Cersei but these are people who were
defending his house these are his people
he's watching getting slaughtered and
you can see that that's rough on him now
let's get to the absolute true
full-on highlight of this show
on I was so good having a bag and then
he gets to be such a badass
gilma that Dothraki you cut his horse
out from under him and then taking down
the dragon oh boy I tell you that that
scene was so tense for me because you
know he reminded me of the Brienne &
Hound fight because of that fight I'm
like I like both these characters I
don't know how I want this fight to go
and I felt the same way with with bran
taking aim at that dragon because I love
broad and I usually really like Daenerys
so I'm like I don't know what I want to
have happen and I like that each he hits
me he got that moment of triumph but the
Dragons not dead because while I fully
predict we will lose at least one dragon
before the season is over
I like that they didn't go down that
easily but he managed to make it out of
life so did Jamie which surprised me
towards the end I was convinced Jamie
was not going to come out of this live
and I suppose technically he could still
drown but I mean come on at this point
with with everything going on the show's
they they need to be definitive about
deaths and that was in because I next
episode is going to start with him being
pulled out of the water whether it's by
Dothraki or by bran or whatever he's not
dead
we're going to get more Jaime it's
actually kind of surprising that we got
through this entire massive fight
without a single notable character death
confirmed that's actually kind of
surprising what's more surprising is it
didn't bother me I mean at this point in
the show it really would have run the
risk of yeah big fight that's nice but
it didn't matter but no it didn't matter
I mean this is a massive chunk of army
taken out so plot wise it matters it's
not a gratuitous fight scene and and it
was energetic and fun and visceral
enough that it worked as a scene in on
itself and it didn't need to eliminate
any of the particular important plot
players at this point so yeah just
really well-balanced really nice and
Bronn
oh you know who have no matter who ends
up winning at the end of this whether it
is seriously whether it is Daenerys
whether it is Jon Snow whoever is ruling
the kingdom at the end of this thing
they need to give Branagh Castle the man
on dates so those are my thoughts on the
spoils of war what did you think about
it whatever you thought drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter I council of geeks give a
listen to the Council of geese podcast I
am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast both of those are available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]